pierre laurin journaliste spécialiste de
la russie bonsoir laura merci d'être
avec nous on vient d'entendre des
relations normales mais sur un pied
d'égalité c'est ce que demande la russie
vis-à-vis de l'europe une illusion qu on
a quoi aux sanctions par exemple je
crois que ce que veut dire le ministre
lavrov c'est qu'il faut mettre les
relations à plat il faut poser les
problèmes sur la table et essayer de les
résoudre
un art 1 mais en oubliant la logorrhée
des sanctions actuellement mais des
sanctions surtout dès qu' il y à un
incident quelque chose qui ne plaît pas
on est des sanctions mais on l'aimé sans
même être sûr de ce qui est s'est
réellement passé
je prends un exemple c'est l'expulsion
de 18 diplomates russes de tchéquie il y
à un mois
les tchèques ne sont pas sûrs que
réellement la russie ait eu quelque
chose à voir avec les la raison invoquée
c'est à dire l'explosion d'un dépôt
d'armes qui n'était pas un dépôt d'armes
officiel mais clandestins en 2014 c'est
à dire que ça remonte à loin
et soudain voilà on a des informations
ne sais pas d'où elles viennent
vale semblablement des états unis et la
tchéquie décide d'excusés 18 diplômes
c'est ça qu'il faut que je crois m'être
mettre un terme à cela il faut mettre à
plat les problèmes discutés et à partir
de là on peut trouver des solutions ou
bien constater qu'effectivement il ya
mené une mésentente
mais dans ce cas les choses sont claires
donc l'égalité c'est ça c'est mettre les
choses d'une manière correcte
enfin ça face et essayer de résoudre les
problèmes
la question qui se pose et c est ce que
les états membres de l'union européenne
puisque là il ne s'agit pas de lune
européenne dans son ensemble même si
elle édicte des sanctions mais c'est la
relation bilatérale qui s'impose est la
relation bilatérale peu dépassé le cadre
justement bilatérale pour engager dans
l'ensemble de l'union européenne mais ça
c'est une autre phase donc c'est pour ça
que le ministre lavrov a été très
réticent
lorsque il est question de négocier
directement avec l'union européenne
l'union européenne n'a pas à lui dicter
avec qui elle va parler en europe et en
particulier là on voit très bien que le
portugal s'est décidée à avoir une
position un peu dissonante
même si la délégation de l'union
européenne est également présente mais
le fait qu'il y ait un état européen qui
prennent une initiative pour aller dans
le sens de la rencontre avec la russie
c'est assez positif
alors c'est vrai que cette diplomatie
mise à mal par plusieurs affaires qui
obscurcissent un petit peu le ciel entre
ces russes et les européens c'est un
requin sru ce n'est faire navalni la
biélorussie également est ce que il y
aura la volonté selon vous de des
membres de l'union européenne d'avoir la
même relation d'égalité que soit cosco
pour le moment il est clair que certains
membres oui mais ils sont relativement
rares mais l'union européenne ont les
mêmes non évidemment la seule chose qui
peut faire changer les choses à mon avis
ça va changer c'est la rencontre entre
le président américain joe biden et le
président russe vladimir poutine le 16
juin en suisse parce que la rai
semblablement la donne politique entre
les états unis et la russie va changer
non pas radicalement bien entendu mais
simplement il va y avoir des éléments de
dialogue qui vont apparaître
et ces éléments de dialogue sur les
affaires internationales sur le
désarmement sont très importants pour
les deux pays
et là on se trouve dans une sorte de
dynamique qui peut engendrer d'autres
choses c'est à dire que à partir du
moment où le dialogue s'instaure il peut
se produire la même chose qui s'était
produit dans les années 60 entre les
états unis et l'union soviétique
c'est à dire arriver à une forme de
détente et la détente et les
relativement simple à instaurer
aujourd'hui on se rend compte avec cette
histoire d'espionnage des des dirigeants
européens par les états unis avec la
complicité du danemark que lé dirty
tricks les sales coups ne sont pas
seulement du côté russe tout le monde
les pratiques
c'est à dire que c'est très bien que
l'union européenne dénonce ce qui se
passe en russie certains événements que
la halle que les états unis fassent de
même
tout cela impeccable mais à condition
qu'il valait un peu de vent devant leur
porte aussi donc là les choses sont
peut-être en train de 2,2 s'égaliser et
je crois que après le 18e le pardon le
16 juin
il y aura certainement une le début
d'une dynamique entre la russie et les
etats unis et il faut que l'union
européenne soit présente parce que sinon
elle va se retrouver largué merci
beaucoup pierre laurent merci d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt front
spécialiste de la russie